sweltering late summer heat is forcing
nearly 120 schools in one of the
nation's largest cities to close several
hours early for the second day in a row
and just the third day of the new school
year we're talking about the city of
philadelphia where the school
superintendent says more than half of
facilities in the district do not have
adequate air conditioning it's just the
latest example of how infrastructure
troubles are disrupting the national
education system elise preston joins us
now from philadelphia elise good morning
good morning tony i'm standing in front
of philly's merited school just one of
the places that will close early today
because of ac issues in a district-wide
assessment this building received an
unsatisfactory rating the students here
face questionable access to water
fountains even stairways to safely exit
the building for some families those
issues seem to be the standard
it's ridiculous they should not be in
school with the heat like this some
classrooms have air conditioning but
most of them don't so it's like hard to
stay focused it's unacceptable mom
sharice workman told us her 16 year old
son jules spent much of his sophomore
year baking at paul robeson high school
jules had to
go to the nurse's office
to
get relief from the heat because that
was the only place that had
air conditioning so workman advocated to
get ac put in over the summer and as a
result her son's school did not have to
close yesterday still the district says
the robeson high building is inadequate
and obsolete missing school is
associated with worse test scores and a
worse outcomes generally american
university professor claudia persico
says philadelphia's shortcomings are
part of a greater national problem a
recent federal survey found that around
54 percent of u.s school districts
needed to update infrastructure and
estimated that students in roughly 36
thousand schools are saddled with
outdated heating ventilation and ac
systems what is the impact
every day and long term on the kids that
go to those schools
heat impacts learning across the school
year potentially making it harder for
kids to learn and focus there's also
evidence that if you take a test on a
particularly hot day you'll score much
lower than if you took a test on a
cooler day as for cherise workman and
her son jules what is the message to
people who can fix this i don't
understand
why
any school district would subject their
students to
unsafe deplorable oppressive conditions
nationally low-income students are
disproportionately hurt by crumbling
infrastructure here in philadelphia the
district tells cbs news that the average
school building is more than 72 years
old and the district is in the process
of installing air conditioning across
the city the whole process could take
two years regular school hours resume
tomorrow nate
oh man in two years at least thank you
it's unfortunate because the ripple
effect
the ripple effect is crazy i mean think
of the hundreds or thousands of parents
who now have to as you pointed out take
off of work or find other arrangements
or the kids don't have any kind of care
and they're doing their own thing and
that's a problem too add another meal
when they were counting on that meal to
be served at school
all the while trying to keep kids in the
house
and why does it take two years to put
the ac in
and that's the problem the schools i
mean schools are such an important tool
in terms of the structure for children
and for parents so we can be productive
and unfortunately some of these inner
city schools they have to deal with the
delays